Google commercials now in the
hour-and-a-half comedy format the
internship so the internship is a comedy
starring Vince Vaughn and Owen Wilson
they are salesmen they sell you [ __ ] in
person in a world where everything
that's sold online so now that they're
obsolete they lose their jobs they've
got nothing else to do so they're like
well hey we'll be interns at Google
maybe that'll lead to a job it'll
certainly lead to a comedy I'll tell you
that which is primarily funded by the
largest company ever the company that
will soon create Skynet Vince Vaughn and
Owen Wilson are good in this movie they
play the characters that Vince Vaughn
and Owen Wilson usually play in comedies
in this movie it really worked Vince
Vaughn's really fast talking and that
works for a Salesman after that of
course the movies gonna be cliche
everyone competing for this internship
job they'll break up into groups of
course Vince Vaughn and Owen Wilson's
team they're all gonna be the misfits
everybody not just them you know they're
the longshots they're the underdogs the
ones we have to root for and then among
all the teams you're really ever gonna
see one other team and that's the
[ __ ] now we have our competition now
we have our comedy it's like the
full-length feature version of the
academic decathlon in Billy Madison or
as Vince Vaughn says it's a mental
Hunger Games with a bunch of geniuses at
a point in this movie where these two
guys are struggling so much to fit into
this group you're like how did we get
here how did this happen so believable
not exactly I do like the fact that the
movie touches on a relevant concept and
that is yeah we're in a digital age but
human interaction that is still
important for success if you're good at
computers and all that [ __ ] don't count
out someone who's just good at being
personable that person might just go far
in the world likeability is a really
powerful thing what would say it's very
important in a world of douchebags Owen
Wilson has to go after Rose Byrne
because the formula says someone has to
have a romantic interest in this movie
I'll say this though I was surprised
rose burns in this movie I should be
like oh yeah hot chick but I got it man
another chick in this movie caught my
eye she was cute who is she no idea I'd
like to see her and more stuff movie has
laughs gags touching moment is a
groundbreaking notes are pretty
predictable formula doesn't change the
fact that I had fun with the movie the
internship I didn't walk out of this
movie saying I need to own it but I did
walk out saying it was a good time no
alcohol required I also call [ __ ] on
the whole Google helpline
one of the challenges is oh you got to
be personable on the phone when people
call Google helpline for help I've never
to Google helpline I do YouTube videos I
should know if a Google helpline exists
I don't think it does so that's just
[ __ ] why doesn't it exist because
Google helpline people would hear one
thing only at this point the YouTube
layout could you just go ahead and
change that back hey the YouTube layout
I just don't like it yeah that YouTube
layout really sucks kids YouTube oh my
god so in terms of comedies this year
what's your favorite comedy so far
whatever it is comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]